[Music]
i found out recently that you auctioned
yourself off for charity a date you
could get an and you know i go to a
bunch of charity functions it's always
you can get like a bag of grapefruits or
something and then
i you know the prizes they're fine but
they're not you auctioned yourself off
for a date
yeah actually you should don't ever do
it don't do it don't do nothing but it's
like the worst idea ever it's like one
of those things where you really i was
like yeah i am a dumb blonde like who
does that who says yes i don't they
approached you and they said would you
auction yourself off and
the correct response is no i will not
but they trick you with the whole people
are suffering
thing
they trick you with that i never fall
for that
i'm like
they trick you with the oh you know you
can help so many people and then you
fall for it and then all before you know
it you're like at a restaurant with some
stranger
like you could end up in dahmer's or par
apartment that way like that's not a
good idea do they vet this person first
so it could be anybody anybody and you'd
you'd be safe in dahmer's apartment
yes i would
actually be all right
[Laughter]
what a horrible conversation
now i have to top you all with an even
worse serial killer uh so you went on
the date and it was and it was okay
please don't call it a date it was it
was a date you went on a date i went i
went to dinner with with a strange man
uh i was so scared actually that i made
two of my girlfriends go and sit at the
restaurant while i was there i mean the
closer i got to this thing i was like
this could actually turn out really bad
like you know like rich people can be
creeps too right right they can rape oh
they're the worst yeah
what this is how did this conversation
go this way
i feel like an innocent bystander it was
just it was really look it yeah i would
rather just like give the money and just
that was just not it's a ski it was a
scary thing it was a really and he was
weird
don't say that he's watching right now
he's clearly an evil rich man watching
right now she has displeased me
i'm just gonna do that for 10 minutes